SPEAKER: So life.
Life is an anti-entropic
phenomenon.
In a universe in which the
second law of thermodynamics,
entropy is breaking
everything down,
life is a brief upwelling
of structure against chaos.
Life moves towards greater
complexity and organization.
Life overcomes limits.
And as Bucky Fuller use to
say, "Life is anti-entropic."
But life means energy. .
And energy, my
friends, as you know,
is a hot button
topic these days.
The dream fusion huge, the
idea that you could put energy
into something and actually
get more energy out
of it than you put in.
And so far, it has eluded us.
But it has captured
our imagination.
And so now, in the south of
France, in the Alpine forest,
a machine called the
International Thermonuclear
Experimental
Reactor is literally
the sparking and the controlling
of a self-sustaining, synthetic
star.
This machine promises to
fulfill the dream of fusion.
It will literally be, honor,
a synthetic, self-sustaining
star.
Mankind, the species that
overcomes and transcends
limits, humanity, is ushering
in its trans-humanity
by potentially solving
the problem of energy.
A self-sustaining,
synthetic star.
The dream to get more energy
out of it than you put in.
So whether it ends up
working, we shall find out.
But just the idea of it, I
cannot think of something more
magnificent.
Maybe a little heretical,
as well, but magnificent.
I just-- [SIGHS] we're
gonna create a star.
We're gonna Create a star.
Just thought it was amazing.
All right, guys.
So be sure to check out
our sister network, Seeker,
where we explore travel,
adventure, culture,
and amazing stories
from around the globe.
As human beings, exploring
is in our nature.
We want to learn and
discover until we
are able to better
comprehend not
only the world, but ourselves.
What is without becomes within.